- Voila, it's a boy wearing a baby belly,
inside of which is a boy,
actually it's hot water.
Motherhood!
Who doesn't want to have a baby?
- He hates looking at me.
I prefer dogs over babies.
- I think the hardest
part about being a mom,
is loving the thing
that's ruining your life unconditionally.
(baby crying)
- And for us as four guys,
there's no way for us
to truly understand what it's like.
Ow! Oh! Ah!
But we're gonna try.
- This isn't how much
babies really way, is it?
How heavy is this?
- How much weight should we
put into our pregnancy bellies?
- About 25-30 lbs, but remember
that's at the end, at term.
- What are these, are
these the baby's balls?
- Probably more likely to simulate
a baby just pushing into your organs.
This already hurts.
- Every time, a woman
talks about a baby kicking,
it's like a magical
thing, but does it hurt?
- Oh!
(laughing)
- [Pregnant woman] It feels
like a punch or a kick,
and you get a few jolts
every now and then.
- It feels like I'm a marine
suiting up for battle.
- I can't keep my hands off my body.
- Oh, ow!
- Already, I'm feeling a
strain on my lower back.
- Strong back, strong baby.
- I'm already tired.
- I'm out of breath from
wearing it and talking.
- It's warm.
- Oh Lord, this heat!
- The warm sack is just heating
up my entire body temperature.
- The baby's heavier,
it's pressing on things.
- You have cellulite,
stretchmarks and you're big.
- It's harder to move around.
- It's hard to sleep.
- Varicose veins and you get hemorrhoids.
- What are some of the positives?
- The baby.
- How much pizza do I get to eat?
- Even though this is very uncomfortable,
I think baby's are a beautiful thing.
- It's nice to know that your
body wants to destroy you.
- I can't imagine doing anything in this.
Like all I wanna do is just sit down.
- [Pregnant woman] It's a big shift.
Your center of gravity has changed.
So you suddenly have all
this mass in the front.
- Pregnant woman sleep on their sides?
I'm going to roll on this side.
Nope!
- [Keith] Oh, this is awful!
- Those little balls are
digging into my ribs.
- Not my balls, the balls in the bag.
Not my bag, the bag on my stomach.
- Let's see if I can get out of bed.
- How do they do it?
- Isn't the point of lying
down, supposed to be to relax?
- I don't know how a
mom-to-be gets any rest.
That was the most painful
thing I've done today.
- Getting dressed is a lot harder.
Definitely before I came here,
I probably put on like
four different dresses,
and I was like, "Nope, doesn't fit."
- I keep getting trapped
in everything I put on.
- I underestimated how big this belly was.
My boobs look amazing though!
- I feel like the worst thing would be
having to buy another wardrobe,
because all of your
clothes wouldn't fit you.
- Does it make my butt look good?
- What am I doing wrong?
Why are you laughing at me?
- Simply 15 minutes,
at eight or nine months
pregnant has been a disaster
- [Eugene] My mom, she was
pregnant with three kids,
and every time, she still wore high heels.
- I couldn't see my feet
or my crotch that well,
so adjusting my pants was kinda difficult.
- I understand now, that
being a pregnant lady's
super hard, can we stop?
- No we're not.
But you can see my balls in this.
- I think it's nice to empathize
with a pregnant woman, but it really is
a complete physiologic change.
Not only just how you feel physically,
'cause it hurts, but mentally.
- [Eugene] I have to go!
- [Ned] Number one or number two?
You should go in that side.
- You know I'm just going to hold it.
- [Pregnant woman] As
I entered from my first
to my second trimester, there was
this deep demon like hunger inside of me.
- I'm going to McDonald's.
[Zach]- How come?
- (beep). This is why.
Two orders of Chicken McNuggets.
- You only need 300 calories extra a day.
- (beep) it, I want 20 pieces.
- Careful with weight gain.
We really encourage exercise.
- It's 91 degrees outside
and I'm miserable.
Nailed it.
- Once I'm down here, I can't get back up.
- A stronger core will
help support the uterus,
and will help with back pain.
- [Zach] Go back, go back, go back.
- No! It hurts.
- [Zach] Then go back.
- Yoga, crunches.
- [Zach] I'm in severe pain.
- Inhale.
- Balance. Graceful.
- What's that feel like?
- It's bouncing all over the place.
- Pregnant Yoga! I'm
not having a good time.
- Just to have to make
that big adjustment,
it's not my life anymore, it's our life.
- I can't imagine having to deal with this
for over nine months.
- I think I understood this
maternal protectiveness,
because I am dealing with so much (beep).
- if anybody tries to (beep)
with me, how (beep) dare you.
- Yeah, but this is just the beginning.
- We haven't even had the baby yet.
- [Pregnant Woman] It only lasts
for a certain amount of time.
It really is a beautiful
thing, and it's gonna make you
appreciate your body so much more.
- I've had like such a hard day,
(beep) try and (beep) with me.
If you try and (beep) with my baby,
I will get out of the car,
and I will punch you in the nuts.
- [Ned] Third trimester what? Bam!
It's a baby in your belly,
you getting pregnant!
Miracle of life bitch!